[Music]
who is the prince that was promised no
promises but house of the dragon might
finally answer that burning question in
the wake of its series finale in may of
2019 hbo's game of thrones left a lot of
unanswered questions one of the most
pressing was regarding one of the show's
many prophecies which were presented
throughout the season only to be dropped
by the finale
among those prophecies one of the most
debated was the one concerning the
prince that was promised also known as
the reincarnation of legendary warrior
azor ahai game of thrones through the
red priestess melisandre spends a fair
amount of time bringing up the
mysterious figure and there are any
number of possible candidates for the
role including jon snow and his presumed
half-sister but actual cousin arya stark
we never get an answer though when the
series ends so does speculation about
this prince that was promised now the
prequel series house of the dragon might
have an answer in the weeks ahead before
aegon's death
the last of the valyrian pyromancers hid
his song at the steel
in the show's first episode when king
viserys decides to name his eldest child
and only daughter rhaenyra as his
official heir he tells her that aegon
the conqueror predicted a long winter
that only the targaryens could fight
which he referred to as the song of ice
and fire then in episode four osiris
shows rhaenyra a dagger resting in the
fire with words inlaid opponents that
also refer to the prince that was
promised from my blood
come the prince that was promised
and his will be the song of ice and fire
what this all means and how it relates
to game of thrones is definitely up for
debate as fans of the original books
know the word for prince and high
valyrian the language in which the
prophecy is written on that very dagger
is gender neutral meaning the term could
refer to a man or a woman with that in
mind could arya who slays the legendary
night king at the end of game of thrones
be this foretold prince however this
dagger seems to specify that the prince
or princess will be descended from aegon
the conqueror arya isn't but jon snow is
to further complicate matters the dagger
is a very same valyrian steel dagger
arya uses to kill the night king fans
will likely never stop debating the
identity and mere existence of the
prince that was promised and house of
the dragon at this point at least is
merely stoking the flames when game of
thrones premiered in 2011 it quickly
became the most talked about show on the
air
drawing huge crowds and becoming one of
the last instances of appointment tv
during an era increasingly populated
with on-demand streaming hits as its run
continued year after year the show only
gained traction picking up major
accolades including a whopping 59 emmy
awards and gaining fans right and left
then in the spring of 2019 the finale
aired and the chatter largely ceased as
one of the world's biggest shows lost
its cultural capital seemingly overnight
thanks to its controversial finale we
can go over what exactly went wrong with
game of thrones from dropped plot points
to ruined character arcs until we're all
blue in the face but there's no denying
that the series somehow ended with both
a whimper and a bang house of the dragon
a big bet for hbo after the outcry over
the finale and final season of thrones
has paid off so far and has even been
renewed for a second season and it does
have a major advantage over its
predecessor and that its source material
has an endpoint clearly marked original
showrunners david benioff and d.b weiss
had to move past george r.r martin's
source material to wrap up the show
whereas martin has already written all
of fire and blood the source material
for house of the dragon hopefully house
of the dragon won't leave us hanging
like the original did but truly only
time will tell
[Music]